hello and welcome to this video playing
light like Martin tunes and what does he
do against this d5 I kind of expected
but I wasn't raised playing the Queens
gambit declined usually so if you
probably get some some sort of red team
you know okay I can see we are taking a
solid option I think this this is a very
decent line for both sides actually
white has some hopes if black is not
totally preside precise White has some
hopes for a slight advantage and I don't
think that this is good actually d for
good you thought that would be good oh
it's see that's running right into
Bishop f4 that early would behave
wow wow so Mia Red Queen to Queen a five
what the heck
hmm okay so who does that just refute
everything what I'm doing here probably
what water we had what we had worked
very weird stuff okay so who
ah what the heck I don't want to play it
off like Bishop g5 when you're just a
pawn down it said really looking at 95
Queenie 5 92 95 it looks very shaky all
of that for black but maybe you can he
can do it probably you can Jesus and you
know this just completely sucks i'm
fairly sure that the aid is not good but
probably not because of what I did I
have to get rid of that bloody d4 pawn
it possible that he's got night see fire
and so this pollution is just completely
dreadful hey I mean if you can take
before and keep everything in my whole
game doesn't make the slightest sense I
mean like not not even a little bit
fantastic
you
yeah it was also bad should go to a 3b6
is now completely yeah run it running
into Bishop a6 and everything yeah it's
very easy to play also this is the worst
thing ever you played let you play badly
it's sometimes not punished you know but
if you play crap yeah and and it's like
everybody sees why it's crap well then
it then it gets really bad okay we can
just basically resign him trip gone to a
3 I mean then of course black is also
clearly better but I'm giving him all
this now with tempo so it's extremely
awful
[Music]
what's best after be aid but should be
sixes the normally move there maybe just
be three I mean I actually think that
our group behind against all agus but of
course he didn't take on play five he
doesn't look for any of those tactics I
don't really know I think it feels like
a headed on the botton in an earlier
game not like earlier today but like
some time ago on the channel
Kim pond take c43 doesn't do that in I
mean he doesn't capture everything is
good everything is good for black here
[Music]
yeah Quincy for those moles they are all
pretty strong I'm just go Bishop before
him
or this one check
d to threatening a new one is pretty
strong I mean enough to win probably
just promote now that's also good then I
think besides this was basically you
know purely opening loss yeah I mean if
I just just kills me I tried I tried I
mean I looked I was thinking for a long
time because if you cannot take for some
technical miracle then I'm just lost
this is why I took a bit of time I you
know I played this very quickly because
I felt like I had it on the board
earlier some game and it was working
okay then but he fibers of course is
strong yeah that basically means that
divorce probably probably bad and I
should play like a normal look like a
four or something that that is a very
normal move like this this and here
black has very good equalizer equalizing
chances yeah this just doesn't work at
all I was trying to make things work
here like this is this what check
actually be not that clear but of course
you can can check me first this is the
thing I looked at this this this but
there is simply no big idea 94 can even
take it I mean and he has moves like
this I'm not I don't have anything
sampling and here the position is more
or less lost your porn down and black
asses commanding oops not this critic
commanding center that that prevents me
from developing my pieces and yeah Queen
B 5 was ridiculous but the position is
probably beyond saving here it's just a
bit too much it's got the porn more
space
Chappelle like Windsor so in important
technical technical idea that I think
I've missed before because i think i've
played this before in games at least in
one game so I should do something
against be fine here b5 not sure
abilities become probably a four is
correct and we have that probably will
transpose to to the beauty six line ok
guys thanks for watching I forgot to
switch on the analysis anyway I think I
told you everything there was about it
thanks for watching